welcome back to the Ingram angle I'm
Raymond Arroyo we told you last night
how John fetterman is running away from
a debate with my next guest Dr Oz ahead
of November's senate election in
Pennsylvania this after claiming earlier
this year that candidates need to debate
well now he's blaming his health after a
stroke he suffered days before the
primary when asked how pennsylvanians
could be assured that he'd be able to
represent them if he won
he reacted by trashing Dr Oz
they are trying to uh not focus on the
the condition of their their campaigns
right now and and when they want to get
into a serious conversation and really
talk about having a debate I'd be happy
to engage in that but right now uh the
fact that they have chose to have a
deeply unserious uh
campaign to just ridicule somebody that
is just uh recovering from a stroke
I'll bet that makes much more sense in
closed captioning uh joining me now is
Dr mehmed Oz Pennsylvania's GOP
candidate for U.S Senate Dr Oz your
reaction to fetterman's comments were
you not in serious conversation with the
fetterman campaign about a debate
of course his response is tragic I'm a
doctor I understand completely the
challenges of recovering from a stroke
I've offered to help figure out a way
for John fetterman to participate in a
debate so people can hear him defend his
far left radical positions I've also
offered the possibility that the real
issue is he doesn't want to actually
come on a debate State she didn't want
to do it in his primary he was sort of
forced to didn't do very well he's now
declined two of the five debates hosted
by Major media organizations that I've
accepted by the way he has not accepted
any questions on his campaign stops
which he's only done three of and I've
done 180. he also went to The Hamptons
for a fundraiser went on MSNBC as you
just showed refused to answer a basic
yes or no question about a debate I
think he's avoiding responsibility for
his radical statements and he's out of
touch with mainstream Pennsylvania
values and by the way he's getting a ton
of money pouring in from the coast from
people don't know how dangerous he is if
you're worried about that go to
doctoroz.com support my campaign we're
going to win now in November but we've
got to have the ability to Define who he
is Dr Oz He has tried to label you as a
carpetbagger I mean if you listen to
these ads you know you're practically
Frankie Valli you're you're a Jersey Boy
forever and ever if you listen to those
ads how do you escape that label
people in Pennsylvania don't care where
you're from they care what you stand for
by the way I live I grew up just south
of Philadelphia went to medical school
in Philly I mean I I've got plenty of
roots here the issue for John fetterman
is he doesn't want to talk about the
real challenges that pennsylvanians
facing I'll give you an example he wants
to release one third of all prisoners no
life sentences legalize all drugs I mean
what's he thinking homicides have
increased 60 percent here in
Philadelphia since you took office
people in Pennsylvania want solutions
they want someone's going to fix the
problems that they're struggling with at
their kitchen table I'm the person to do
that John fedman doesn't want to talk
about those topics Dr Oz as you just
mentioned fetterman says it's high time
to legalize marijuana listen
the War on Drugs needs to stop and we
need to legalize weed across this
country then you add in the revenue then
you add in the jobs for our Farmers for
our veterans and just the freedom of it
this idea that we have allowed a plan to
be illegal and criminalized in this
country is absurd now fetterman is
Marching In A Labor Day parade with Joe
Biden and asking him to legalize
marijuana before he arrives now
fetterman's also launching a large-scale
pardoning project for people with
non-violent marijuana criminal
convictions in Pennsylvania Dr Oz first
what's your reaction to this
legalization and this pardoning project
and why is he only marching with Joe
Biden do you think
well I didn't join in Joe Biden for
either the two other events he had in
Pennsylvania listen my issue is that he
wants to legalize all drugs he even
supports heroin injection sites and we
have the largest open-air drug Market in
the country here in Philadelphia it's
destroying the city fetterman is out of
touch with what's going on in
Pennsylvania he's completely missing the
target pennsylvanians need help in the
things that they're struggling with
right now that includes cost of living
crime and the open border with fentanyl
that's hurting our young ones now Dr Oz
I do need to get you on the record here
just two years ago you said that weed
was an under used tool and that it was
safer than alcohol what changed
oh no I'm supportive of medical
marijuana I think with the doctor's
involvement especially for seniors who
have end of life issues suffering from
pain I think it's a safer solution than
for example narcotics in many cases but
it has to be studied and we have to
understand it and therefore Physicians
should be involved I don't want to give
marijuana to every young person in
America who's struggling with getting
through their day we already have a
problem with getting folks mobilized to
enter the workforce I think that's a
slippery slope doctor I need to talk to
you also about the polls polls are
tightening here fetterman's only up two
in four in one of the most recent polls
I saw that is a big plummet for him why
do you think these polls are tightening
so does it have something to do with his
condition and as a medical professional
is the health that fetterman finds
himself in today disqualifying
Raymond I don't know about his health
because he hasn't told the true story
The the transparent story that's
required around his health but people in
Pennsylvania are getting frustrated that
he refuses to engage me in talking about
the real challenges we Face the topics
that I know everyone is struggling with
in their homes as they watch the show
right now and he's being held
accountable for that that's why the
polls have closed our campaigns you know
pumping well we've gotten all the right
topics I'm more interested in making the
lives of pennsylvanians better every
single day to fix the problems that's
what doctors do and again Dr oz.com if
you want to help me Dr Oz after that
report showing how school-aged children
fell behind because of the covet
lockdowns the White House is trying to
rewrite history about school closures
watch
we were in a place where again schools
were not open it shows you how
mismanaged uh the pandemic was and how
the impact of that mismanagement had on
the on kids progress and academic
well-being Dr Oz this White House and
the CDC worked with the teachers unions
to keep close schools closed your
reaction to that
Raymond the White House weaponized
science and we mix politics and science
politics and Medicine you get politics
that's all that's left they literally
pushed us to close schools to offer
mandates here in Philadelphia we have
mass mandates again for children in
school and preschoolers have to wear
them all year round there's no medical
defense for that and yet they're willing
to do it because the teachers unions
desire it I don't understand the benefit
and more importantly I appreciate the
damage that's done by putting a mask in
a child not letting them see the world
and see the mouths of people talking to
them because they don't learn as well no
it's an outrage and you see the horrible
scoring in that nation's report card
today Dr mahmet Oz I thank you for being
here hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else